finally it is here from today we can all
become film directors yes text to video
and image to video that is open source
and free for all of us and it can even
make images of memes come alive this is
stable video which has studied 600
million videos and we have this two and
this two oh my three amazing papers
yummy so what is going on here well
simple you just write a piece of text
and stable video can generate a video
for you in about 2 to 3 minutes it
compares favorably against the
competition at this moment I say at this
moment because this result was recorded
at a particular point in time and these
systems improve so rapidly that for
instance Runway may be way better by the
time you see this comparison but it
doesn't end here not even close there is
another text to video AI that you can
kind of try right now and there is even
more in fact there is so much going on I
don't even know where to start dear
fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr car here so first stable
video this was trained on about 600
million videos and now can generate new
ones for you it is free and open source
however you still need some
computational resources to run it I'll
put potential places that can run it for
you in the video description if you
found some other place where other
fellow Scholars can run it for free
please leave a comment about it thank
you it takes approximately two to three
minutes to create a video and there is a
lot to like here finally an open-source
solution this means that you will soon
be able to run this on the phone in your
pocket as freely As You Wish glorious
however it is not perfect not even close
sometimes you get no real animation but
instead a camera panning around also you
probably already inferred that from
these results but it cannot generate
longer videos but that's not all is
generated videos also typically showcase
not too much motion third you know the
deal don't expect good text outputs from
it not yet anyway and fourth it is a bit
of a chunker what does that mean well
you need a lot of video memory to
perform this I am hearing 40 GB although
there is already a guide to get it down
to under 20 or maybe even 10 GB link is
in the description from seeing the
nature of these limitations my guess is
that the memory requirements will be cut
down substantially very soon however
there are more tools coming up in the
meantime here is emu video this is
incredible look it is so good at
generating natural phenomena and it even
has a hint of creativity wow fantastic
results and the paper showcases this
which is a sight to behold goodness are
you seeing what I am seeing this is a
user study where humans look at the
results and whatever other technique you
see this compared against it has a win
rate often in the 80% region against
image and video here is what image and
video look like and that is definitely
one of the best ones out there and now
this new one still better wow but it
gets better just creating high quality
results is not enough just consider a
technique that always gives you a high
quality video perhaps always the same
and ignores your prompts that is a high
quality result however faithfulness to
the PRS also needs to be measured and on
that this new technique has no equal
nothing is even close wow and fantastic
news you can kind of try this technique
out for free in a website right now the
link is obviously in the description
waiting for you fellow Scholars you can
assemble these text Proms and see
immediately what the system will do with
them I love the creativity here every
solution is at least pretty good in my
opinion and some of the solutions are
just excellent for instance this one ha
so good you can also look at some images
here and perform image to video These
really came to life here so good or
search for a gallery of text to video
results I loved the robots here but when
I looked for scholarly content nothing H
we need more scholarly content well
maybe next time also this is a great
paper so it contains a study that is so
much more detailed than this they also
look at sharpness smoothness amount of
motion yes you remember from the stable
video project that this is super
important and object consistency as well
now not even this one is perfect the
resolution of these videos is 512 by 512
not huge but this is almost guaranteed
to be improved just one more paper down
the line also this is not open source
not at the moment anyway now why is it
important if it is free and open source
like the previous stable video well have
a look at this I love this image so why
is this interesting well have a look and
you see here that the best performing
large language models are all
proprietary these are closed models
however there are other language models
that that are nearly as good just a step
or two behind but these are free and
open source so this means that
intelligence is not in the hands of just
one company but a nearly as good
intelligence you can run yourself on
your laptop and soon on your smartphone
too just imagine if the best model out
there is unwilling to help you or starts
hallucinating in that case you would
have no other choice but with open-
Source models this will never happen
there is always going to be a kind
Little Robot helping you and this is the
importance of Open Source models and if
you think that we are done well fellow
scholar hold on to your papers for the
third amazing paper for today emu edit
this helps us edit images iteratively
the iterative part is key here this
means that we can start from an image
that we like something that we got from
a text to image AI perhaps and then it
is rarely the case that everything comes
out exactly how we envisioned so from
now on not a problem at all we just add
subsequent instructions and much of the
image will remain only the parts that we
wish to change will be replaced so if
you need the same emu the same
background but make it a fireman there
we go
and oh my look finally scholarly content
good and when compared to the
competition this one is also so far
ahead of them goodness look at that
instruct PX to PS is just from a year
ago and Magic Brush is from less than 6
months ago and both of them are
outperformed significantly here there
are other cases which are a bit closer
but I still prefer the new one here so
three amazing use cases three amazing
papers I hope that you share my feeling
that this is an incredible time to be
alive research breakthroughs are
happening every week what a time to be
alive subscribe and hit the Bell icon if
you wish to see more if you're looking
for inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda
now offers the best prices in the world
for G GPU Cloud compute no commitments
or negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with the Lambda GPU Cloud
you can now get on demand h100 instances
for just1 199 per hour yes
$199 and they are one of the first Cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 accs did I mention they also
offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and ctech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today